je vais profiter de mon intervention
pour vous donner l'état des lieux de la
situation aujourd'hui dans notre pays
vis-à-vis de l'épidémie pour que chacun
puisse se rendre compte de la situation
à laquelle nous faisons face il y a ce
soir 131 1863 patients qui ont été
diagnostiqués et confirmés par pcr pour
le coronavirus ce sont donc 5 176
patients de plus au cours des 24
dernières heures 51 1371 patients guéris
parmi tous les patients hospitalisés
mais il reste encore ce soir 25 1548
patients hospitalisés
c'est certes une réduction de danse 267
patients par rapport à hier
mais ce sont encore près de 6 ce sont
d'ailleurs précisément 699 admissions de
patients supplémentaires à l'hôpital au
cours des 24 dernières heures
la france déplore 25200 un décès ce sont
3 106 décès de plus sur les 24 dernières
heures
enfin il y encore ce soir de notre pays
6455 patients dans les services de
réanimation dont 3696 patients atteints
du coronavirus dans les réanimations
c'est certes 123 lits occupés de moins
par des patients atteints du coc vide et
ce sont 84 à une mission supplémentaire
ces chiffres vous y êtes habitué je vous
en donne la primeur ce soir à l'occasion
de mon intervention
ces chiffres derrière ces chiffres il a
une situation hospitalière qui reste
tendu qui reste difficile il ya une
épidémie que nous avons combattu avec
succès grâce au confinement et grâce à
l'action des français depuis de
nombreuses semaines mais que nous
n'avons pas totalement vaincu loin s'en
faut